[Musique]
vous savez où nous sommes
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes sur l'espace naturel
sensible
eden liberia à bras panon
[Musique]
nous sommes si heureux la forêt de
l'éden liberia qui a une superficie
totale de 458 hectares
cette forêt là elle appartient au bon ça
a été pas de mental de la réunion
alors le petit sentier qui nous ramène
sur le point de vue où l'on va pouvoir
découvrir
un superbe panorama c'est à dire un
point de vue magnifique de sept usines
jusqu'aux éoliennes de sainte rose bien
sûr
il faut venir quand le temps est super a
dégagé pour pouvoir profiter de ce
panorama exceptionnel
avant d'arriver
au site nous avons nous pouvons
admirer petits champs de thé
laissé à l'abandon pas le propriétaire
monsieur jo de wolf ont donc c'était un
ancien député de la réunion
[Musique]
alors ici nous sommes en présence d'une
des nombreuses orchidées de la forêt
donc là on est en présence d'une entité
épiphytes bon aujourd'hui le parti qui
n'a pas su arrêter on la retrouvera t il
mais généralement on va la retrouver
sur un support donc sept ans qui décès
la famille des envies comme en
l'occurrence celle là c'est l'engrais
comme mauricienne donc c'est une très
belle foule ces blocs idée qui va donner
les jolies fleurs blanches
qui va débuter sa floraison de loisirs
de masse à avril à peu près et donc on
va dire que cette floraison et va tenir
à peu près un mois et dès que la fleur
et va être ses comptes et elle va virer
va passer du de la couleur blanche à aux
jeunes
[Musique]
nous sommes en présence d'une espèce qui
va tenir son ou par rapport à son fruit
d'accords voilà le fruit en fait ils
ressemblent vraiment un aplomb et donc
son nom logiquement ça va être pas de
piment et en période de floraison ça m'a
donné une toute petite fleur blanche à
cinq pétales
[Musique]
alors ici nous sommes en présence d'un
bois de corail
or il faut savoir que chez nous à la
réunion on a deux boîtes corps est
différent on a le chassa lien coralie
-dès donc celui qui donne vraiment la
fleur qui ressemble à un corail marin et
puis on a cette variété là qu'on appelle
aussi boîte mail donc lui il va donner
une floraison qui ressemble pas vraiment
un corail marin mais il voit plus
ressembler à olso café d'ailleurs c'est
la même famille la famille des rubis non
vraiment de couzeix se ressemblent
vraiment de la forêt d'ailleurs il ya
plein de gens qui confondent le bois de
corail et le bois de le bois de l'eau
son café qui sont vraiment proches
[Musique]
avec le concours financier du
département
nous pouvons
entretenir le site avec lui puis
contrats aidés et des cdi et des des
agents d'entretien emplettes à la presse
à
la gestion de cet espace naturel
sensible depuis 2004 son rôle sur sur
l'éden liberia c'est la restauration des
milieux naturels l'entretien de 15 km de
sentiers de randonnée et la
sensibilisation et l'éducation à
l'environnement
[Musique]